WILL BERED WITH THE MOST
HEINOUS ANUT MANNEE
PE
YOU WORKED FHE MILHES OF INJURIU
HAVE  FOR -
MILITARY IN AFGHANISTAN FROM 20T
AS A LOCAL,ATIONA
WAUPO BEGINNING OF MARCH
ST I WOR A
CIVILIAN CTR
THHO TT TIME WORKING
WITH THEPS IN IN A VERNDLESS T
, ANECADE, AND PROFILE.
PEOPLETH UNDERSTANDT WORKTROOPS
AFGHANISTAN, WHA OF SITUATION M
WHAT I HAVE SEEN THERE, S.E WITM
BOHA AND SPEAKS WHATND BN H.
K
DO MY FAMILY DVE TO GO
THROUGH THAT KIND  THAWHAT -I IE
I ONLY HAVE  TO SPEAK,MEERK, TH
OUSANDD THOUSANDS OF
CAERICAN AT EVEN HAVE TH
GOING EVE WSEIS THEOMIS - MY S
NT AND A 5 YEARS OLD
DAUGHT YING,WAE FOR SEVEN OR UPO
>> TO THE AIRPORT?>> TO THE AIR.
AND THENATERTH
CALLED ME AND TOLD ME THATHEY,
DO YOU WO AMERICAN NT WAN ALIVE?
I TOLD HIM, WHAT ARE YOU TALKIN?
D ME THAT THERDEATH AND U MAKE O
GUARANTEE IFEVACUATED.
ENHE, CO
BACK NEXT DAY.
IT'S A DANGER.
YOU PUT US IRE
N ALLIES.OE
WE ARE WATCHED BTHPITTIN OUR
THEY ARE ARI
OUIC AN AM.
CITIZEN AND YOU -- YOUR LYIS HA
THEY A IN DANGER BECSETHHAT YO
WHAT LED TO YOU BECOMING AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN?
WHY DID YOU BECOME A
CITIZEN?
>> WELL, I BAME AN AN
CAE
IS NOTA -- THE WORLD
AMICAMERICA ISIGNITY.USE
AMERICERS.
LE- ALME TO, TY MESSAGE  ENT
TROOPS IN AFGHANISTAOUTIONATIDO
SUD AND ED
U.S. TROOP THAT WE ARE
WORKING TO CONVIE THE CONCAUTHO
OT THAT YON FACED AMERICA MEANS.
AMERAN TROOPS WOULVEEE WE.OPEYEN
AFGHANISTAN.
THEY AREOR
RYL FO THAT I HANJED,  SEVERE.I
DISRESPECTY  S OF
OLDIERS THAT HAVTHHER OOHAME.
I ANY TARY F  VERY PERSONAL
IN MY CHEST, IT'S IN MNG>> Y
IT -- I HAVE 20-PFARS AT RII H.
, , TO,
IS HEARING THATHERE IS
SOMEE HE, WHATOING TGHK, IO SAH
LFBUT YOUR
LYU NG
>> YOU'RE MOSTIT'S -- I AMAMERIN
I AM AMERICAERE ISO DIFFERENCEE
MEMERICANS
AMN AMERICAN.
THIS IS FAMILIES OF .
WE LOST THE  L W
CI,  SORAL SHOD SHOWO
T. HE
TORKING FORLLIES
GOINGTHE SITUATION.
CHECKINU AS
TH
>> YOU'RE MOST WELCOME
TO HEAR.AT IS THE
AT SEE HOW
HIS SERVICMILY
ATS FLECT
ON KNOW,Y W
LY HAVE ES. VERY FVE
>> THERE ARE AF AFGHANS VED IN S
ISSI C FAITH.
HIS FAMILY IS
WE MAY HAVE LOST THEE
LOSTHE
TH I SEEUP T DIGNITY, NESIRIANN
USM A MI - HUSBAND HAS
TR TOVY NOT BEPING UP IC.
>> THERE IS LIKE -- I'VEN
CALLING IT A DIGITAL DUNKIRK
D IT'S VETE , YO,
PEOP L H